[Music]
farmers often ask
whether they can combine their inoculant
with
seed applied pesticides when they're
sowing their legumes
in fact this was a leading issue
when we did a survey a number of years
ago that farmers really wanted to know
more about this topic so we're doing
some research on this at the university
of adelaide
and we're part way through that research
what we've found
so far is that of the fungicides and the
insecticide that we've tested
that thyram is particularly toxic to the
inoculant bacteria
so we haven't found any inoculant
bacteria that
are not killed by thyram and also
this goes to p pickle tea which contains
thyram as an
active ingredient plus evershield which
is
almost the same as p pickle tea so
thyram and people tea are the two seed
applied pesticides
to watch for and we have
some evidence from the lab and also from
the field that
the fungicides quite toxic to the
bacteria and can reduce
nodulation substantially
so what we're suggesting is that farmers
separate out the inoculant from
the seed by putting either a granule in
furrow
or putting a liquid stream in furrow if
they've got the capability of doing that
either a peat slurry or a
suspension of the easy rise freeze-dried
bacteria
in 2018 we did a field trial on the air
peninsula at the minipa
in the manipur region and the treatments
consisted of
peas coated with fungicide pickle tea or
not coated with pea pickle tea
then we added a peat formulation of
inoculant
or a freeze-dried formulation of
inoculant called easy rise
and we put the inoculant on either 24
hours before sowing or
one or two hours before sowing really
the only treatment
that gave us decent nodulation was
peach with no fungicide the other
treatments just failed to deliver on
nodulation and in fixation
in that field trial the fungicide was
quite
detrimental to nodulation
the other thing to note about that trial
was that
the conditions were really dry so we
think that
having that dry soil stress
plus the pesticide stress on seed the
combination of that really
affected the nodulation and in fixation
if a farmer does really want to coat the
seed
after applying the fungicide we've got a
number of suggestions
as to how to cope with that stress one
is to double the number of
bacteria double the dose of bacteria on
the seed
so we get a better chance of good
nodulation
and to sow as soon as possible after
coating the inoculant
because that will also lead to greater
numbers surviving
so into moist soil if you possibly can
as
ideal conditions and also finally
go into a paddock where you've already
grown that legume and have that
inoculant before
so you'll get a decent background to
start with we hope
so that should minimise any problems of
the toxicity
[Music]
you